it was a no choice decision it killed me
that I had to sell me home after 40
years yeah it's either that or you watch
your own family go under
Joe has only moved 50 yards from one
side of her street to the other she's
selling up so that her daughter can
afford Child Care well I did nothing but
crying break me off for months and
months but none of this was my choice
then we go she works nights and by day
looks after Felicity and Frank so that
their mum Fiona can hold down her job as
a manager at a logistics company even
with such a great job great career you
know it's still not enough Gareth is the
family's health visitor here in ilkeston
in Derbyshire you want to see what she
weighs today yes
this is a happy loving and successful
family who are faltering through no
fault of their own it's not normal is it
people don't mind going to her and will
work hard right and we'll do everything
but the time it gets to where you wait
wait and you still have no money that's
when the population will start turning
do you think politicians get it no I
don't think they do which I think they
live in a different cookie land
altogether talking to normal everyday
people no they don't go
not clear at all to be honest I don't
know how optimistic I am in terms of any
change
um I'm just hopeful because if you don't
have that hope it's despair if you
haven't got hope it's just despair and I
do believe that's you know it's a
never-ending Vortex of you know mental
health issues and depression and anxiety
and it kind of then makes you question
you know what is the point
and this is the price that so many
people are paying the cost of paying for
the pandemic the cost of the war in
Ukraine the cost of inflation it's
hitting everybody for whatever level
from those that have always been
deprived to those that have actually
never been in any Financial struggles
are struggling in a way that's
immoral
so then it says here let the worry go
yeah it's what Kath sees too she's on
the same Public Health Team let the
where we go and maybe share that worry
with with somebody else yeah School
nurses like Kath don't just sort out
injuries and illness there are so many
families that we are getting in touch
with or getting in touch with us that
potentially in the past we might not
have have known who they were we have
young people that we've you know have
come to school they're really hungry
we're having to try and look for ways to
find food for them and you know there
are young people coming to school in
dirty clothes and often they've layered
up as well so they're putting numerous
layers of clothes on because it's so
cold at home have there been any moments
in the last few months where you've
thought this is more serious than I
thought there are definitely moments
when I feel really concerned about
the amount of young people that we are
seeing that are really struggling with
their emotional health
it's become all too familiar struggling
parents and children with fewer and
fewer opportunities at some point
there's going to be there's going to be
a generation of children that will lose
because of the cost of living
something's got to change something's
got to change soon
the chancellor may have something to
offer but the budget will focus on the
figures it always does the cost of the
cost of living is about so much more
than just money
Tom Parmenter Sky News Derbyshire